damn it
all right who did this
I'm not mad I just want to know who did
it so I can punish them what are you
talking about uh someone uh forged
medical information and that is a felony
okay whoa all right because that's a
pretty intense accusation how do you
know that they're fake ah leprosy
flesh eating bacteria
hot dog fingers
government created killer nano-robot
infection
you did this didn't you absolutely not
yes you did no I didn't I know it was
you okay fine you know what I'm gonna
have to interview each and every one of
you until the perpetrator makes him or
herself known and until that time
there will be no Health Care coverage
for anyone
killer Nano robot
epidemic
Michael I just found enough skill
precedent in the rules that might just
save everyone what's up bomba John don't
need it
uh okay hmm
ready when you are boss Eleanor what's
going on it took me a while to figure it
out
but just now as we were all fighting and
yelling at each other and each one of us
demanding we should go to the bad place
I thought to myself man this is torture
and then it hit me
they're never gonna call a train to take
us to the bad place
they can't
because we're already here
this is the bad place
[Music]
oh man
I can't believe you figured it out
[Music]
what they're gonna even say what they
gonna do she asked me the whole thing
and I didn't even do it once I'm like an
elephant okay if I walk into a room it's
like okay he's in there
Baba Boy
turn this music down
[Music]
today
is this everybody and took a cab time's
in the trunk Jerry's on the roof
all right where to First
your mother's butt
[Laughter]
I'm so alone
if even one of you thinks about dry
heaving in my car you're all walking
sorry Amy could you let me do it do you
mind if I tried thank you purchased at a
Cloud9 store no all the victims were
solid to evenly portion pieces with
their genitals preserved in pickling
jars that makes sense we sell pickle
jars it's not working we're gonna have
to drown this out
um Everybody sing okay down in the
valley where Ezekiel wept cry Ezekiel
cry come on what's wrong with you
Garrett give me a beat or something
anything
the finger of the devil is poking
through the foam cry Ezekiel crack climb
it out and the slide to Hell goes all
the way down cry Ezekiel
I vomited somewhere in this room I don't
remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friend nothing like a complete
physical breakdown to make a guy seem
less intimidating
I love the flu
oh thank you you're welcome
ah
I'm so so sorry for the temperature in
here
the um sliding glass door shattered
it's actually a really cute story do you
want to tell it babe or should I tell it
I don't like that story babe come on
it's a cute story Michael ran through
the sliding glass door because he
thought he heard the ice cream truck
stop it I mean I like ice cream okay sue
me oh no don't I shouldn't say that
jokingly because she will sue me she
loves to sue she loves lawsuits you know
honey that door was extremely clean and
it looked invisible you are so right you
are so right because before I lived here
the glass was always covered in smudges
and then I moved in and I cleaned it so
I guess that makes me the devil
you are she is she is the devil I'm in
hell
I'm burning help me you shouldn't jump
about that everybody is mad at us
mostly mad at you yeah well that's
because Donaghey threw me into the deep
end of a pool that I didn't want to
build in the first place
look I'm just saying we both screwed up
today I think we should make nice and
buy everybody some pizzas and some soft
drinks this is what we're gonna do lemon
you're gonna get everybody on my Yacht
Harbor Cruise drinks togetherness that's
great you have a yacht I got a yacht I
got a solid gold jet ski two Batmobiles
the AIDS monkeys bones 901 Amy Santiago
is officially late for the first time
ever all right let's do this who's got
theories uh uh alarm didn't go off all
three alarms all with battery backup
come on who wants to take this seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about super dark foil
but way more plausible than the Sarge's
idiotic alarm clock Theory I bet she
tucked herself into bed too tight and
got stuck maybe she fell into another
dimension where she's interesting it's 9
A.M
why is no one working Amy Santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why I like to play
I'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
Subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself I'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it Santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
God damn all right you're burning up
you're burning up what I have to get out
of here I have 2.8 body fat my body's
like a microchip a grain of sand could
destroy it
my body's microchip
Leslie no I can't I can't go home I have
to get ready for the Chamber of Secrets
Commerce if this meeting does not go
perfectly then the Harvest Festival is
going to be over before it begin I
cannot go home okay then who's your
doctor
and my doctor
she's the most beautiful nurse in the
world
come on oh God now I'm hot now it's
really hot here okay well that's your
fever
Leslie I typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
sure
you should get one of these no thank you
do you even know what this is
it is a fitness orb and it has
completely changed my life
forget everything you thought you knew
about ab workouts done this ab workout
is specifically designed to strengthen
your core
all right
numerous health benefits
strengthens your back
performance in sports
more enjoyable sex
you're not having sex
plus improved your reflexes
I would have caught that okay you know
what uh how much is that
it's only 25 bucks wow